goodmorning believes nation today we're
going to talk about how to deal with
haters lesson number four is our
personal favorite and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end for some
special bonus clips and as always as
people are talking if they taste help
them it really resonates with you please
leave it in the comments below and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
what I love my aliens because my haters
are gonna show me things my friends and
my family not gonna tell me here is it
going to be very quick like they're
haters because they said it you so they
know a thing or two about you and so you
can all communicate it it's like any
information can be recycled but I don't
allow my haters to penetrate my spirit I
don't allow them to throw me off of my
plans and like you if I got a hater I'm
not saying well my hate I always found
talking about oh I don't waste time you
know getting engaged in the stuff that
they want me to get a day I say focus
and do it I'm supposed to do but I
listen to them to see is there anything
there same as proper that I can adjust
there's four things when some gives you
feedback or criticism however its
intended whether ill are positive and so
one is not to take it in but to kind of
catch it I think it's like a catcher's
mitt if you tell me something you come
across this way I'll grab it and then
I'll look at it and I'll think okay is
it true it's true cool I'll put it in
and learn from it I think it's not true
cool I'll throw it away no harm no foul
I'm not going to dwell on it right and I
think everybody needs us in this world
because we're all on most of us are in
social media and we're all getting Slyke
you know all our stocks are getting
picked apart you know all the times who
really need this more than ever then the
third one is you get it and it's a maybe
well I'm not sure you said this about me
and not sure you know what you guys
think you know what do you think I lost
my friends and asked other people and
get some feedback and if it's true well
cool maybe I'll learn from if everyone's
like this is total nonsense ignore that
dude I throw it out then dip it under
the fourth one and this is where the
real growth is do you know what the
fourth one is the fourth one is you get
it you throw it out I'm talking to you
in the mid to later I'm talking to you
know you I get it and I'm like now it's
not sure I throw it out and later I'm
talking to someone else I get it it's a
third time it's come back to rest Oregon
I'm like wait maybe I got to take this
thing a little ornery and it becomes it
maybe and then it becomes a yes and
that's when the big real thing is
because you kept ignoring this thing
that was in your face so the best
feedback like where you really grow if
you keep getting the same feedback you
keep dismissing it at some point you say
wait maybe they have something so one
way I do this is I get together a group
of people and we sit together once a
week and talk about the stuff going on
our lives
I find group therapy really powerful
because if it's just one-on-one I can
just say I disagree with you but when
four or five people are saying hey dude
no you're really coming off like that or
you're really having this problem your
relationship and maybe need to look at
it and five people are saying it like
it's pretty hard to dismiss them Prince
as we was taking his last breath there's
a big shout out to print them a huge fan
I don't think Prince cared what
Billboard magazine said or what anybody
said it's just the way it is it's the
way it is and so it's through this plea
on this show onto a one on a Monday in
late spring if I could get four of you
to understand I could get four of you to
understand it's just not going to matter
people I mean I love them people I'm
vitally notice to tell you I'm going to
say it very clear I just let Stefan get
very focused here because I want to
really deliver this with all the drama
that it deserves and I like when people
put me down I get off on when people put
me down
nothing is more interesting to me than
to prove all of you wrong I love the
people that think I'm a huckster or I've
got some hidden agenda or I'm not that
good or I won't be that great or I think
too big of myself or my dad at a liquor
store and that's the only reason I'm
successful or I got lucky or does this
desk asbestos that the depth of does
that show me like please Eve please
continue to judge me and underestimate
me because it's the only driver I have
and that's how I'm wired and I don't
expect all of you to be wired that way
but if I can through my energy move any
of you and trust me I'm reading your
comments because your comments on my
oxygen and I see so many of you so many
comments over the last three or four
months of people saying hmm I've got a
little more cockiness or confidence than
I used to remember I seen you guys
actually see my inner circle have more
confidence when they were like it just
rubs off I mean you're getting cocky
have you felt it yeah yeah I know I've a
lie them but it's true right there
there's a rub off its kind of like a
leader on a sports team like it rubs off
and one of the great accomplishments in
my life will be the fact that I was able
to rub off my confidence not only on my
inner circle but on the community that
decided to give me it's unbelievable how
good I feel that I get to reward the
amazing reward that you give me which is
in all the things that you could be
watching right now you're watching this
and all the things you could be reading
spending time on time you decided to
watch me me do you know how incredibly
empowering that is except scale it's not
doing people you don't powering it is
and for me knowing that not only do I
give you tactical advice or in a funny
way that I answer question number three
a girl in Indonesia might say well if
Gary Vee is bad at math and has been
successful I can to or in this ending
and you can care a little bit less when
your coworker or your older brother or
that naysayer says or what I know so
many of you deal with which is the
trolling and the hate and the and the
disagreeing even when it's done well and
I love when people disagree with me in
the comment section I take it for this
even when that happens you know pissed I
was a daily be thirty
how many people like emphatically were
drilling me for a bad episode fine but
like after all like and that's fine and
I agree and we didn't do a good job
setting that up and I don't think I set
up the rock for success at the genre
that he's not as passionate about I
could have done a better job I
understand that but it's blows me away
of how much venom people can put up like
like after you provided you're only as
good as your last at-bat two hundred
great episodes of a business show
stories great episodes of the doc you
show five thousand interviews of
business stuff unbelievable engagement
answer your questions answering a staff
boom one baseball fantasy thing and pure
and utter disagreement thus parchments
hate negativity that's hard I'm the most
competent and it felt bad and I didn't
like it so what do I expect from others
I get it but it is what it is and at the
end of the day it's not going to matter
and you have to love yourself first but
I feel good and complete with yourself
first so the 15 year old I would do what
I did as a 15 year old would you start
building those skills and not listen to
your parents and not listen to your
teachers and not listen to your friends
respect it but don't let anybody anybody
impose their way on you it's you you're
with yourself and you've got to make
yourself happy first don't give away
your power so anytime some nasty
criticism or bf comes your way you have
to say this you cannot take me down I
will not give you that power I want you
to make that your new mantra in life you
got to realize that people can say
whatever they want but you do not have
to take it in and you don't have to let
it ruin your day your time on this earth
is so precious and it's really really
important that you protect your soul
empathize
you know a lot of people who are being
in a negative mood or negative energy
you don't know why you know you've had a
bad day too you've been rude yes I know
you're amazing and you watch this show
and you're really into personal
development at the end of the day you've
been rude to people too you've had a bad
day you snaps you've been impatient
you've hollered you've been a jerk when
you shouldn't event you know it well
other people do too so when somebody is
negative always wonder I wonder what
happened today that led to that you know
maybe the kids got out the wrong side of
bed and they were just horrible that
morning and that person didn't sleep
last night maybe something happened with
their family maybe on the way to the
work they just thought of something very
depressing in their past maybe the truth
is right now they're so unclear about
who they are and what they want in life
that they're taking out on other people
maybe their own failures their own
struggles their own disappointments have
ravaged them and led them to you know
depression led them to mental disorder
the reality is we never know someone's
story and once you can teach yourself
that I really believe you become a
better human you become more
compassionate you're better at listening
you're better able to understand because
you have the intention to sympathize and
say all that persons are really in a bad
place right now you don't take ownership
of that say well I didn't cause it you
just say simply ah they're in a bad
place I hope they're okay you know I
think it's a real true personal power of
you walk by negative people and still
say I wish you nothing but joy and
health and strength and love in your
life to have that hope for people even
when they're in a bad place
that's humanity your critics don't
matter
has there ever been a statue built of a
critic
I remember the great writer Paulo Coelho
said that he doesn't think about his
critics that's their job and it made me
realize that that is so true you see so
many of us we spend our time worrying
about people who don't serve us
I say I am letting go of whatever no
longer serves me to make space what the
hell inspires me and that is that
beautiful prana baby right now in the
grand scheme of criticism right we can
write essays we can write essays on
criticism because it's so exciting look
at it like this many people stop having
fun you play it safe when someone
criticizes you so when I first started
to make videos someone said gosh Ralph
that video so long it was only for a
minute so I said actually okay I'm going
to take on board what you say and the
next video the next video was 26 minutes
can I get a Hello there you see I made
videos with my hair all over the place
and some people said Ralph your hair
looks terrible
do you know how I felt yeah I felt like
that it was really hard and I thought
okay I've got to make my hair like this
I got to make my hair like that then I
said actually my hair does not define
who I am I am NOT my hair I am so much
more so that gave me the strength to
face screw it and for many years I made
videos my hair all over the place and
guess what I love this can I get a hello
there do whatever you want
say whatever you want go wherever you
want and if anybody's got a problem with
that screw them
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because one of my
teammates Ivan who does a lot of the
research for these videos wanted to put
this one together so Thank You Ivan for
all the work and if there's a topic that
you'd like us to cover in the next
edition of Belize life please leave it
in the comments below and I'll see what
I can do I'm also curious to figure out
what was the biggest lesson that you
took from this how are you having a hard
time dealing with haters and maybe the
one of these strategies stand out from
the rest I'm super curious to figure it
out leave it in the comments your
experiences below and I'm going to join
in the discussion finally I want to give
a quick shout out to my publisher Mary
and Lizzie thank you so much Mary for
all your support in the launch of my
book your one word and proposing that
awesome unboxing picture on Instagram I
really really really really appreciate
it so thank you guys again for watching
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
I am one who always welcomes criticism
and I increase people you should welcome
tradition and we bold enough to give
criticism if the criticism is coming out
of Dino valence that I want that someone
is criticizing so that I can become
better then it is always welcome but if
someone is criticizing just total
jealous you are trying to pull someone
down then that is not good then that is
coming from a male if ik mindset so
constructive criticism I feel everyone
should welcome criticism with compassion
criticism Fadlallah its most adorable
thing and it should always be welcomed
to use their energy use that energy they
put out there use that challenge for
your own character development really
see when I'm someone's negative around
me I don't sit there and I don't become
a victim oh gosh that's negative I don't
go home and assume their energy and now
I'm negative instead I go you know what
this is a moment to test am I really in
command of my emotion and how I sink or
are they am I giving my power over to
the world so that they can just take my
energy and turn it to what they want or
am I in charge so I use it as a
challenge not as something I don't have
to challenge or change them immediately
I also get to that point but I get the
point where say you know what huh
here's a little challenge of world's
throwing me right now can I stay on my
game can I stay centered
can I stay peaceful can I stay calm can
I stay present right here right now and
not have to run away from it not have to
pretend it's not there but you I
encourage you to do that because if it's
just something that you immediately
complain about well then in your
complaint you you just let them win
their negativity has turned you into
noticing what is negative and you lost
you're not winning even if you can
critically you know
should throw a barb at it make fun of it
you're still losing you're being sucked
into their pools of pessimism you're
drowning
so I say used it recognize it and use it
Oh criticism look the thing is the thing
is that you know in the beginning it's a
little funky but you got to realize that
everybody nowadays has an opinion
everybody's a critic and you know you
can watch my video on YouTube and leave
a comment you can go to iTunes and buy
my album and leave a comment you could
tweet whatever you want you know and
you're going to drive yourself crazy if
you really take those things seriously
you know they're just everyone's not
everyone is going to love you